by the revelation that philip k dick do
you mean the incidents that happen to
him and that spawned looks like valence
and the divine invention
well i won't spend too much time on that
because i don't know how many people
know who philip k dick is I think it was
Robert Anton Wilson who coined the term
Chapel perilous this is when something
happens in your life and it all begins
to fit together and make sense too much
spin because it's coming from the
exterior and it eat and it seems to
either mean that you're losing your mind
or you are somehow the central focus of
a universal conspiracy that is leading
you toward some unimaginable
breakthrough I don't know what that I've
experienced it maybe anyone who leads a
long and eccentric life who has these
periods where they seem to have caught
the wave and are being territory to
unimaginable revelations and situations
quite beyond their will this is what
happened to dig and the explanation for
these kinds of things would lead us
quite far afield I would just say brace
briefly and bravely that I think
[Music]
vortexes of connectedness seem to haunt
time like those and they're not material
objects so they're too subtle for
science to
there's something known to shamans poets
gamblers people like that and these
vortices of coincidence and
connectedness can work either for or
against it and if you don't have a model
that contains the possibility of these
things then when they come upon you you
will become highly agitated and think
you're losing your mind or you're being
contacted by aliens or something like
that I call it and I don't think I'm the
first but I call it the cosmic giggle
and you know it comes after you
sometimes you just have to be rest able
to wrestle the best particular aim
turns up on your daughter
[Music]